Дарині 14 понад півроку вона прожила в
окупації в рідній голій Пристані що на
Херсонщині у вересні разом з родиною
дівчина виїхала до Одеси батьки швидко
влаштувалися на роботу а сама Дарина
відновила навчання в школі і записалася
на професійні курси які в Одесі
запустили спеціально для дітей
переселенців
взагалі я прийшла на кулінарний курс
через те ну взагалі аби краще навчитися
готувати або більше навчитися готувати
також від цих кулінарних я дізналася що
є ще багато курсів із них зробили разом
курс так скажемо лідерства там де
ораторські здібності краще стають від
всіх ораторських здібностей йдуть ще
курс французької та англійською це також
дуже прикольно
спеціальні професійні курси для дітей в
Одесі запустив благодійний фонд добрий
самарянин який ще 30 років допомагає
дітям сиротам пенсіонерам А тепер і
переселенцям яких в Одесі нині близько
60 тисяч для них щоденно працює
гуманітарний штаб а волонтери
організовують творчі майстерні для людей
будь-якого віку проте фонд окремо
вирішив приділити увагу саме дітям
найбільш вразливі категорії внутрішньо
переміщених осіб підлітків переселенців
навчають кулінарній перукарській та
манікюрній справі була ідея
соціалізірована ідея соціалізувати дітей
дати їм можливість познайомитися один з
одним а також навчитися професії це така
до професійна підготовка Зараз ми хочемо
запустити школу професії для якомога
більшої кількості підлітків не лише в
Одесі а й Одеській області нині на
безкоштовній основі у нас навчатимуться
протягом півроку 32 дитини також
відкривається ще один напрям мудрий
Тесля це навчання з різьби по дереву для
хлопчиків додатково відкривається курс
лідер ства а також курс з вивчення
англійської і французької мов і
дополнительно курс ледерства английський
французский язык
кожен зі слухачів курсів прийшов на
навчання зі своїми цілями й бажаннями
ми розпрашували у наших учнів
навіщо вони тут яка їхня мета і
насправді дивовижно те наскільки різні в
них цілі хтось хоче робити мамі манікюр
а хтось хоче опанувати майбутню професію
усі абсолютно різні
асвоїть будущою професією поэтому все
абсолютно разные разом з Дариною
кулінарну майстерністю опановує
13-річний Олег що таке війна знає з
шести років саме стільки йому було коли
навесні
2014-го рідній Краматорськ захопили
проросійські терористи маленький Олег
був свідком запеклих боїв у місті аж до
самого звільнення Краматорська 5 липня
однак у 2022 російські ракети такий
вигнали його з рідного дому
кожну ніч стабільно були прильоти
началось звужуватися кільце надвоєму
містом Ми вирішили що все вже якщо
ми не виїдемо то
мабуть Все буде як в Маріуполі
курси професії Олег довідався від мами
але рішення записатися на них ухвалював
самостійно мені мати і показала з
телеграм каналу
оповіщення що ось йде набір на
кулінарний курс безкоштовно я вирішив
Чому б не почати
саморозвиватися і вирішив поїхав Мені
там більш-менш сподобалось Я часу собі
нормально і вирішив знову туди приїхати
сьогодні я вирішив шукати для себе нове
життя так кажучи і
насправді я зараз знайшов друзів саме
така соціальна складова коли підлі
переселенці завдяки професійним курсам
знаходять нових друзів украй важлива для
дітей наприклад я ходила до цього курсу
ще на одній курси то там також знайшла
достатньо друзів і тут просто знайшла
подругу
для нас дуже важливо щоб була увага до
дітей така психологічна підтримка тому
що діти дуже вразливі більшість із них
виїхали з окупації дуже тонкі такі
натури і ми хочемо щоб наші зустрічі для
них були підтримкою натхненням та
мотивацією підлітки можуть обрати
будь-який курс або ж поєднувати навчання
одразу за кількома спеціальностями серед
викладачів провідні спеціалісти Одеси
які на волонтерських засадах допомагають
переселенцям здобувати нові знання та
віру в свої сили приміром один із
викладачів курсу перукарської
майстерності власник мережі барбершопів
Євген Дяченко чому Ми займаємося цією
справою то чому навчаємо взагалі от ви
бачили учениця була в її цікаво і вона
просто прийшла подивитися Наша задача
першочергове це
впровадження нашої культури в маси
хочеться всіх
приєднувати до нашої культури барбітуру
приєднувати до того щоб всі слідкували
за собою серед слухачів курсу 15-річна
дар’я і Сєвєродонецька рік тому дівчина
закінчувала дев'ятий клас і планувала
розпочати професійне навчання на
перукаря але почалася повномасштабна
війна і замість того щоб готуватись до
вступу Дар'я рятувала своє життя Тепер
дівчина нарешті має змогу втілити свою
мрію як дитинства хотіла стати перукарем
та
довго планувала довго хотіла просила
батьків щоб вони все ж таки дозволили
піти після дев'ятого класу вони після
11-го як вони хотіли Ось я їх вмовила
Але почалася війна
Аня підлітки здобуватимуть
практикуманітарному центрі приміром усю
їжу що готуватимуть на кулінарних курсах
роздаватимуть нужденним а перукарські
здібності Діти зможуть випробувати
роблячи зачіски пенсіонерам які
приходять до благодійного фонду по
допомогу також невдовзі стартує курс зі
столярства який триватиме три роки
долучитися до школи професії можуть всі
охочі діти переселенці усе що потрібно
згода батьків та довідка про статус
внутрішньо переміщеної особи
[музика]